this building was once home to the
families that lived here now many of the
residents are buried under the debris
the voices from under the rubble are
fading with every passing minute
and those alive and safe are exhausted
by the torturous weight
sometimes losing temper and control
four days now they have been standing
here hoping to see their loved ones
coming out of the debris alive
and if not at least recovering their
bodies to give them a proper burial
tension is running high and time is
running out
bodies keep coming and anger Rising
has saved his mother but his younger
brother is gone
he says he is the oldest among siblings
and his younger brother shouldn't have
died first
we are suffering pain I don't want
anyone else to experience this
many lives here have been torn apart and
families shattered
now Rescuers are trying to save whatever
is left
authorities say the two earthquakes that
hit the city released energy equivalent
to that of 500 atomic bombs
the scale of Destruction is immense the
country has not seen a bigger disaster
in a century
the Turkish disaster Management
Authority says the duration of the first
earthquake that hit Southern turkey was
65 seconds while the second one lasted
for 45 seconds the area was shaken
severely for about two minutes as a
result around 1 000 buildings collapsed
and nearly 6 000 people died in karaman
maharash those who survived are now
trying to cope
these very families now have nothing
more than hope
the window to save people is shortening
and the cost of failure is too high
we've been working for days without
stopping I'm mentally down but I have to
stand firm and continue to work because
they're relying on us
there has been some positives as well
and hard work has gone through it here a
five-year-old Syrian girl is being
pulled out alive after 132 hours under
the rubble a moment of Celebration and a
spark of hope for those still waiting
as the night falls on the rubble in
karaman marash these rescue dog sniffs
through the debris it detects the smell
of someone below possibly alive
and it is time again for the steady and
delicate rescue work
Russo Sardar Al Jazeera karaman marash
Southern turkey